Hedge funds are among the most
computationally demanding environments
I know of.
They have infrastructure
requirements like huge databases,
significant network connectivity,
low latency and
high bandwidth connectivity,
real-time processing, and so on.
I want to show you as an example,
the typical kinds of computing
that goes on inside a hedge fund
to motivate you for this class.
In other words, this isn't exactly
the way all hedge funds work, but
this is just to give you a taste for
how many hedge funds work.
And you'll see, I think,
that computing and
computational capabilities
are core here.
So we're going to work
backwards from the market
back towards the sort of back
office of the hedge fund.
The way things work are we have
certain portfolio that is which stocks
we have and whether we're in positive or
negative positions with regard to them.
The trading algorithm here is central.
It's interacting with the market,
observing the live portfolio.
And what it's trying to do is
to get this live portfolio
to match some target portfolio.
So somewhere further back
inside the hedge fund
we've decided what this target
portfolio ought to look like.
In other words,
how many shares of Apple, how many
shares of Delta Airlines we should have,
and so on, and this trading
algorithm is trying to get us there.
So it's comparing target with live.
And then to move this portfolio towards
that target, it's issuing orders.
So it sends order like buy 200
shares of Apple to the market.
Those orders get executed or not,
and that updates the live portfolio.
Now one reason this kind of
trading algorithm is important
is you don't want to
execute everything at once.
In other words,
suppose we wanted to take a very,
very large position in Apple.
If we were just to send an order, hey,
buy me 10 million shares of Apple,
that would affect us detrimentally
in the sense that the price for
Apple would probably rise.
And we would not get a good execution.
So this training algorithm takes those
sorts of things into consideration as
it moves our live portfolio to be
more close to the target portfolio.
In fact, sometimes it takes days
to enter a particular position.
So this doesn't necessarily
happen all at once.
And there's many, many different
types of trading algorithms that have
been invented to solve these problems.
Now let's step one step back into
the computing of the hedgefund, and
look at how we arrive at
this target portfolio.
Here's that target portfolio,
and here is some of the data and
computing that could go into
computing that target portfolio.
So from somewhere, machine learning
perhaps, we have a forecast
of what stock prices are going to
be at some time into the future.
And that can of course drive what our
target portfolio ought to be for today.
In other words, if we're forecasting
that BAC is going to go up,
this might represent that we
think it's going to go up 5%.
We might want to increase
our holdings in that.
If we think that Apple, for instance,
is going to go down,
we might want to decrease our holdings.
So this forecast informs this algorithm
called a Portfolio Optimizer.
That works to balance the risks and
rewards for
a balanced portfolio that
considers volatility and
correlation between different stocks and
so on.
We're going to talk a lot about
portfolio optimization later in this
course.
Some other considerations that go into
Portfolio Optimizer are historical data,
open, high, low, close, and volume.
We can look at that historical data to
inform how stocks are correlated or
uncorrelated to one another, and
also of critical importance
is our current portfolio.
It may be the case that if we're
holding something, we don't
want to exit it immediately because
we'd be penalized by rapidly selling it.
So this optimizer takes all
this information into account
to get to the target portfolio
that our trading algorithm is
working to drive us towards.
Now one more stop along our road here at
the computing infrastructure of a hedge
fund is to look at how do we come
up with this N-day forecast.
By N, N might be five days or
ten days or whatever.
So here's this N-day forecast, and we've
got some kind of forecasting algorithm.
This is very often in
the form of a model, in fact,
a machine learning based model.
And creating these sorts of forecasting
algorithms using machine learning
is the focus of the last mini-course
in this group of mini-courses.
Anyhow, how do we get to this forecast?
Well, we've usually got some
sort of proprietary information,
again, historical data, and
our forecaster crunches all that data
to build a model and create a forecast.
So, bringing it all together,
that's the computing in a hedge fund.
And we've also spent some time
talking about what might motivate you
as a hedge fund manager.
That's it for this lesson.
I'll talk to you again soon.